President Trump is making the case for
his re-election tonight while also
making a statement about the pandemic
19,000 supporters are expected to put
social distancing concerns aside as they
convene in Tulsa for an event which
defies the recommendations of the
president's own coronavirus task force
the rally was pushed back a day for the
observance of Juneteenth celebrating the
end of slavery in this country certainly
in Texas events are expected to continue
in the city's historic Greenwood
district today but the with Oklahoma
case is seeing an uptick in covent cases
there are concerns the rally could be
super spreading are becoming a super
spreading event Omar Villafranca has
more from Tulsa this morning Omar good
morning good morning the line actually
just shifted we've seen a mad scramble
of people trying to pick up their tents
and kind of move the line closer and you
heard that correct hundreds of people
with their tents they camped out
overnight because it's a first-come
first-serve event now yesterday the
president put out a tweet and he was it
was basically a warning he told them you
will not be treated like you have been
in New York Seattle or Minneapolis it
will be a much different scene now this
rally that's happening here in Oklahoma
and it's the timing is of course
questionable according to health
officials because they're seeing a surge
in cases cases are up 158 percent in the
state compared to two weeks ago Tulsa
County saw three record days in a row
for daily positive cases team Trump says
they will pass mass SAP but they're not
mandatory doors open up at 3 p.m. at the
BOK Center the event is scheduled start
at 7:00 p.m. so people will be inside
that arena for several hours and that's
why local health officials are saying
and pleading with people to please wear
their masks inside now 100,000 people
are expected in downtown Tulsa there's
also going to be plenty of security
besides Tulsa police and sheriff's
deputies there's also going to be 250
national guardsmen and more than 200
state troopers in the area on standby
just in case
Oumar thank you very much all eyes will
remain on Tulsa today